you may remember elon musk during all of
this uh subsequently he said this on
twitter which was pretty good
suspending the account the twitter
account of a major news organization for
publishing a truthful story was
obviously incredibly inappropriate okay
so that's pretty good right so that's
what he said a while back and as you
know he is in the process we believe of
buying twitter it's a little unknown
what's going on because he had these 10
days where he went silent on twitter
then he came back suddenly
two days ago and guess what he said this
is literally
uh from look at this
5 17 a.m on july 5th now i got banned
about an hour and a half before this
someone had asked him
if they had if he had seen that jordan
peterson was banned he wrote yeah
they're going way too far in squashing
dissenting opinions okay
so elon musk
you know that they took out jordan
peterson elon musk you have no
you undoubtedly
know that they have taken me out now are
you buying this thing are you going to
fix this thing are the hopes that we've
pinned on you either justly or unjustly
are they are they worthy are you going
to do the right thing i hope that you
will
um but i do know also that if you try to
do the right thing they are going to
come for you we absolutely know that
there has been hit piece after hit piece
about you elon musk since you decided to
get in the twitter game since you
decided to say hey i'm going to defend
speech what did they start doing they
started calling you alt-right and a
racist and all that stuff and of course
they also went with their double speak
you may remember this one this is from
about a month ago uh this is just
i mean this is one of the most
incredible videos i've ever seen this is
from the televised mental institution of
msnbc they've got a host that nobody
watches this shows guys his name is ari
melber but the you know the machine
loves these people who just say nothing
lie about everything confuse everything
accuse you of doing what they're doing
etc etc listen to what he said in case
you missed it when uh the whole elon
getting twitter thing was breaking if
you own all of twitter or facebook or
what have you
you don't have to explain yourself you
don't even have to be transparent you
could secretly ban
one party's candidate or all of its
candidates
all of its nominees or you could just
secretly turn down the reach of their
stuff and turn up the reach of something
else and the rest of us might not even
find out about it till after the
election
elon musk says this is all to help
people because he is just a free speech
philosophically clear open-minded helper
you see
they tell you what they're doing
that's what they did during the election
turn things down
turn other things up that's what they do
then a guy comes in and says more voices
less censorship
let's see what's really going on here
and they freak
out about it so once again i want to
reiterate what jordan peterson said
about ellen page who was a woman her
entire life who is still biologically a
woman
and i don't care about her i don't care
to make this about her but what jordan
peterson said about ellen page was a
hundred percent true and i cannot call
ellen page who was the actress in x-men
elliott page because that was a woman
named ellen page
now what's interesting is not just that
what jordan peterson said was true of
course it was what the new york post
said was also a hundred percent true and
they paid the price for it too